Footage.
Oh really?
Yeah.
The,
the show time.
Dot.
Had like the footage of the,
that show.
Oh,
the show where he was prepping like where he's getting ready to,
well,
not all like the show were just taking go like,
you know what Steve,
you want to stay with them while they filmed the,
you know,
that strip show where he had to come back the next night and kind of Redo it.
He just had like,
he was just,
he,
you know,
operating from such a place of just like,
it was so odd.
It had to be honest to him I think.
And it had just hadn't gone up in a while and was on stage and it was just like
in the room and just sat in.
It just,
he just sat,
there was,
footage is crazy.
Send me that.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's really,
who's got the footage?
Well,
it's in the dock.
You can see it in a documentary like a little bit,
but I think it's extended for it.
I haven't seen the extended footage if that exists,
but
there's some great old cassettes that I bought from a,
like a gas station.
There were a red foxes comedy club,
Red Fox had a comedy club and prior would go up and just fuck around man,
just fuck around.
And there was many of them.
I mean there was like seven or eight recordings,
Mavericks flat,
I think it was right.
That was the name of the company off of like Crenshaw or something over there
like,
Oh,
where the club was,
I don't know.
I got them when I was living in Boston,
I was living in Boston and I found them like at a gas station there were for
sale.
Oh yeah.
And it was crazy because it was like,
it was small crowd,
you could tell it was a small crowd and prior was just fucking around man.
He was just,
he was ad libbing.
You could tell that like it wasn't structured and some of it was really funny
and some of it like kind of fell flat and you can hear the clink of glasses and
shit in the background.
And it was just so real rich,
you know,
Richard Pryor back then,
he was doing something that it's like he had figured out a thing that he could
do that other people hadn't figured out.
And that thing was like,
just be totally honest.
And also just explore ideas onstage in front of people,
like not even have it mapped out yet.
Just try,
just fuck around and find what's funny.
And he'd be smoking cigarettes and just talking and he figured out a way to turn
and then you would see it boiled in to like Richard Pryor live or live in the
sunset strip or any of his specials.
You'd see it boiled down to this.
Yeah,
yeah.
Doing it for,
tell it,
you know,
he performed for television really well.
Um,
and,
and that's like kind of,
uh,
an element that,
I think people kind of forget that.
Like how well of a,
it connected with you watching it at home.
Like,
you know,
even me,
20,
30 years later after it's filmed and just watching it with my dad,
it,
he plays really well here.
You know what I mean?
Like to you,
it's like you can feel how personal and how honest it is and like,
so when it was like boiled down,
it was just,
he was also captured really well.
Did you ever see him live?
No.
Prior?
Yeah.
Wait,
how old do you think I am?
No,
he was alive.
Uh,
doing stand up 10 years ago?
Yeah.
Maybe a little bit more,
maybe 15 years ago.
He died.
Uh,
maybe it was more than 15 years ago now that I'm thinking about it.
Is you ever seen him live?
Yeah,
I had,
um,
I had a follow him like five weeks in a row,
man.
Really Weird.
Like I'll run in 2005 he died.
Okay.
So it was more than I thought
he did a run before he died.
It was probably right before then.
Um,
actually I want to say it was like the late nineties,
early 2000,
somewhere around then.
He was real sick and they would have to carry him to the stage and it would take
like five minutes for him to get to the stage so that he introduced him and the
comic would get out of the way.
And then,
um,
uh,
chewy and Maryland Martinez husband would help him walk to the stage.
They would hold on to him,
take him to stage.
It may take forever.
It was a slow process and they'd get them and they sit them down and they'd
crank up the mic like this.
Sure.
Because his voice was so soft bowling.
Yeah.
And he would do stand up.
I do like 15,
20 minutes and then I would go on after every,
almost every time it would be me and,
uh,
just eat shit shit.
First of all,
nobody knew who I was.
And second of all,
they just saw Richard Pryor and they're sad because he's fading away.
Yeah.
Right in front of everybody.
It's an interesting feeling.
Like never before.
It was like a British type in emission,
been needed more British type information,
you know,
like where it's just like,
all right,
Richard Pryor was gone and uh,
you know,
15 minutes people go smoke cigarettes,
come back.
What year did you start doing stand up?
A 2008 yeah.
So you missed it.
Yeah.
Did you go to the clubs at all before then to look around?
Uh,
no.
Well,
yeah.
Two nights before.
My first time,
two nights before your first two nights before our first time I went to,
uh,
the comedy store.
Wow.
Yeah.
Did you my first day in la?
My first day in la,
I saw the whole show nine to 2:00 AM.
Wow.
You sat through the whole show,
the whole show did the open mic that Sunday.